two generations of Togolese women queue
up to choose a president one is excited
to vote for the first time I mean I am
now 20 years old and happy to exercise
my right to vote not everyone gets this
chance the other was voted in every
election in the past 15 years is back
again this year by coming out to vote
every time that's my way of trying to
change institutions that don't work I'll
do this as long as I live opposition
leader
Jean Pierre Fabre cast his ballot in the
capital the former journalists and
rights activist has challenged president
foreignness ma at the polls for more
than a decade he is unhappy for the
run-up to this election list of
romantic issues which the government
when the complaints is a possibility of
fraud and denying access to opposition
party agents the opposition hasn't been
able to form a united front boosting the
re-election chances of a fourth term for
president foreign yes MA he voted in
clear around four hundred and twenty
kilometers away from the capital
confident of extending his 15-year rule
and fifty three years of his family's
dynastic the president succeeded his
late father erred amania sembei who led
togo for thirty-eight years after
seizing power in a coup voting which is
monitored by local and international
observers passed up peacefully in most
parts of the country it's a few hours as
voting started in this polling station
but the crowd has thinned out the
Election Commission says that's because
more polling booths like this have been
open to speed up the process but some
Togolese have stayed away unsure if
their vote will make any difference
counting the votes is expected to take
longer this time less than 48 hours
before the polls open the Election
Commission announced a change to the
counting process the Commission cited
when it called credible information the
process of transmitting results
electronically from outside the capital
had been targeted by hackers something
the opposition is skeptical about Hamid
Idris al Jazeera know me